[Musica]
[Applauso]
Eppur si muove
Queste sono le parole che pare Galileo
Galilei this nel 1633
all'uscita del processo del Sant uffizio
Ma perché Galileo fu processato
Galileo Il portavoce di una teoria che
era stata enunciata da Copernico qualche
anno prima che diceva che
non era più la terra al centro
dell'universo ma La Terra ruota attorno
al sole e quindi la terra perdeva la sua
centralità la teoria esistente era
considerata vera da più di duemila anni
la denuncia Aristotele duemila anni
prima
bene Galileo stava mettendo in
discussione una credenza una teoria una
verità che era stata ritenuta
intoccabile per 2000 anni e quando tu
fai una cosa di questo genere
la gente non ci crede ti considera un
folle La maggior parte altri magari non
gradiscono o si arrabbiano e questo è il
motivo per cui fu processato Ma cosa
aveva fatto veramente Galileo di così
rivoluzionario aveva detto la terra
l'uomo non è più al centro dell'universo
La terra è un pianeta che ruota attorno
al sole Questo fa tornare tutte le cose
spiega il moto della terra spiega le
moto degli altri pianeti attorno al sole
e quindi semplicemente aveva guardato un
problema la descrizione del moto della
terra da un punto di vista diverso
aveva cambiato prospettiva con cui
guardare la realtà Ecco Questi sono i
così detti i cambi di paradigma nella
scienza e quando
una persona ha uno scienziato un
ingegnere vede le cose da un punto di
vista diverso a cui nessuno prima aveva
pensato e questo ti apre nuovi orizzonti
e la cosa veramente interessante che
quando succede questo c'è un balzo in
avanti della conoscenza
e poco tempo dopo magari in
contemporanea magari decina danni dopo
magari un secolo dopo c'è anche un balzo
in avanti della conoscenza
non solo della conoscenza ma anche nella
tecnologia E questo poi ha un impatto
nella nostra società
dal 1600 in poi ci sono stati tanti
Balzi in avanti tanti cambi di paradigma
nella scienza Io vi vorrei raccontare
tre storie e tutte queste tre storie si
godono si collocano circa un secolo fa
all'inizio del 1900 quindi portiamo
indietro le lancette del nostro
immaginario orologio di andiamo
all'inizio del 1900 e la prima storia di
cui vi vorrei parlare è dovuta a questo
signore Joseph John Thomson
detto j&j per gli amici
che
stava facendo era un fisico inglese e
nel suo laboratorio
giorni no se si direbbe un laboratorio
polveroso nei sotto nelle cantine
dell'università in realtà per l'epoca
era un laboratorio di avanguardia bene
questo scienziato studiava con un tubo
catodico quello che una volta c'era
nelle nostre televisioni
studiava le missioni di vengas
sottoposte a campi elettrici e magnetici
tuoi colleghi servono ba è una ricerca
poco interessante ma Thompson scoprì
dopo poco tempo che in questi tubi
venivano prodotte delle particelle
Niente di nuovo ma queste particelle
avevano una massa 1000 volte inferiore a
quella dell'atomo più leggero quello
dell' idrogeno ora pensate che all'epoca
si pensava che l'atomo fossi
indivisibile che non ci fosse nulla di
più piccolo rispetto ad idrogeno bene
lui una particella 1000 volte più
piccola
e la trovava con quando riempita quando
riempire il tubo con atomi di idrogeno
ma anche con altri casi quindi era una
particella fondamentale è una cosa
arrivo Luzio Naria aspetta un po' di
tempo e poi dopo nel 1897 andò Royal
institut e presentò il proprio risultati
alla comunità scientifica
era una scoperta rivoluzionaria c'è
qualcosa di più piccolo dell'atto
Ovviamente tutti i suoi colleghi per una
multa se scettici un'ossessione e senza
alcuna base scientifica però Thompson è
una persona autorevole e nel giro di
pochi anni li convinse che la sua teoria
era corretta e quindi nel 1906 fu
insignito del premio Nobel questa
particella si chiamava elettrone e
questa è alla base di tutti i circuiti
elettrici che non conosciamo la cosa
interessante e che nello stesso tempo ci
fa anche un balzo tecnologico un cambio
di paradigma prima si diceva l'app non
può essere diviso e adesso sappiamo che
c'è anche le particelle più piccole
cominciò tutta la fisica subatomica
quella che Adesso studiamo nel grande
acceleratore con marce di Ginevra ma
contemporaneamente un altro
inventore che si chiamava Thomas Edison
aveva inventato la lampadina aveva
cominciato a studiarla anni prima e
praticamente in contemporanea con
Thomson brevetto la prima lampadina
elettrica in realtà prima di lui c'erano
questi due signori su Anna e crudo
persone assolutamente sconosciuta che
avevano prodotto le prime lampadine Ma
il merito di Edison fu Che riuscì a
convincere tutti a usare le lampadine le
brevettò e cambiò la vita del mondo
della nostra società Infatti si fa solo
da un'illuminazione con le candele alle
lampadine elettriche che usiamo fino
adesso fino ai nostri giorni
Questo è il primo
cambio di paradigma sia tecnologico che
scientifico che viene praticamente in
parallelo all'inizio del 900 ci
spostiamo dall'Inghilterra all'austria e
c'è un altro fisico
Wilhelm Conrad roentgen
nel 1895 chiusa esattamente lo stesso
dispositivo di Thomson studio e gas e
trovo una cosa assolutamente inaspettata
opre
che oltre alla luce nei tubi catodici
viene messa un'altra radiazione
elettromagnetica che una particolare
proprietà riesce impressionare le
pellicole fotografiche
interessante però la proprietà veramente
straordinaria che riuscivi a
impressionare le pellicole fotografiche
anche quanto era dentro una scatola e
anche se ci mettevo davanti un mattone
quindi era una radiazione che riuscivo a
passare attraverso gli oggetti era di
nuovo un tipo di radiazione sconosciuta
che lui chiamo Non a caso raggio x
passiamo altezza c'è il tel X c'è il
raggio e c'è il raggio x Vabbè a parte
gli scherzi
annunciò la sua scoperta nel
1995 fu una scoperta rivoluzionaria e
Pochi anni dopo nel 1901
consegue il premio Nobel questa è una
storia interessante pochi mesi dopo i
raggi x vennero usati in medicina in
tutti gli ospedali per fare radiografia
e comincio la radiologia moderna e la
medicina moderna Ma questa storia non
finisce qua
c'è stato un cambio di paradigma nella
scienza un cambio di paradigma nella
tecnologia Ma se noi andiamo avanti e
facciamo un balzo avanti di una
settantina d'anni
passiamo a facciamo andare avanti le
lancette del nostro orologio e arriviamo
all'inizio della fine degli anni
sessanta e l'inizio degli anni settanta
e ci sono c'è una casa discografica che
tutti probabilmente conoscete che si
chiama Yamamay e mi che produceva i
dischi dei Beatles Dai questa casa
discografica aveva anche dei laboratori
di elettronica avrei computer e aveva
due ingegneri che lavoravano in questa
casa discografica in questi laboratori
uno si chiamava godfrey hounsfield e
l'altro si chiamava Alan cormack qual
era l'idea di anfil scusate io ho tante
lastre fotografiche tante fette tanti
immagini che affetto un corpo che
effetto non un oggetto Ma se io mi metto
tutti insieme non posso avere
un'immagine tridimensionale
di questo corpo
cormac aveva sviluppato una teoria
matematica che permetteva di fare questo
però non si riusciva non c'era
abbastanza I computer non erano
abbastanza veloce non c'erano abbastanza
fondi Beh la casa discografica la Emy
produce i Beatles loro lavoravano lì e
li convinse loro convinsero la casa
discografica investire i soldi avevano
le entrate
raddoppiate o anche di più da parte a
causa della produzione dei dischi dei
Beatles di sì ma perché non investite
quanto avete guadagnato in questa
ricerca bella e mi fece e nel
1971 fu prodotta la prima TAC tomografia
assiale computerizzata
Grazie una casa discografica
e da lì fu possibile fare delle
radiografia tridimensionale non si trova
il più possibile per la prima volta
studiare un cervello umano facendo una
fotografia
1979 questi due signori vincono il
premio primo premio Nobel per la fisica
e sono ingegnere non sono medici Laterza
il terzo cambio di paradigma è sempre in
Europa sempre all'inizio del Novecento e
gli scienziati hanno un grosso problema
nonostante conosca nell'altro magnetismo
nonostante conoscono quasi tutte le
leggi che permettono di scrivere il moto
dei corpi non riesco a spiegare come
funziona un atomo perché un atomo è
stabile e non riesco a spiegare un'altra
effetto effetto fotoelettrico
quando alcuni materiali sono i nominati
dalla luce
emettono corrente elettrica cellule
fotoelettriche quelle che abbiamo nei
nostri cancelli bene
Gli scienziati non riescono a spiegare
questo è una
certo numero di loro capitanati da niels
Bohr Heisenberg che producono una teoria
rivoluzionaria la meccanica quantistica
che dice sostanzialmente che nel mondo
subatomico le leggi della meccanica
classica non valgono una particella come
l'elettrone in realtà la posso
considerare anche un onda lo stesso
tempo e Questo spiega la stabilità
dell'atomo di idrogeno
l'energia prodotta da una radiazione
non viene scambiata con continuità non
posso scambiare la quantità di energia
che voglio ma viene scambiata a quanti a
quantità discrete Cosa vuol dire
Supponiamo che l'energia sia
come l'acqua che scorre in un tubo
l'acqua potabile Beh noi possiamo
riempire una tazza
tappo e mezzo due tasse mezzo litro
d'acqua
3000 80 quello che ci parlo sempre
Quanta acqua ci pare Beh se l'acqua
fosse quantizzata potremmo produrre solo
bottiglie da mezzo litro posso avere
mezzo litro un litro un litro e mezzo
bene questo spiegò l'effetto
fotoelettrico e così la meccanica
quantistica che una teoria completamente
controintuitiva difficile da capire
spiegò tutti fenomeni subatomic si
fece
generò una nuova teoria e generò una
nuovo campo di ricerche Ma qual è
l'applicazione Questo è un cambio di
paradigma di conoscenza ma c'è stato
anche un cambio di paradigma tecnologico
legato a questa scoperta questa nuova
teoria
è un modo diverso di vedere la realtà
Beh la risposta è sì dobbiamo fare un
passaggio in avanti di 50 anni andare
Nei laboratori della Bell
Dov'è questi tre signori
Bardin breaktime E so che li producono
per la prima volta il primo transistor
fino a quell'epoca avevamo avuto le
lampadine le valvole termoioniche quelle
che c'erano delle televisione nei vecchi
computer va il primo transistor permette
di fare un salto di qualità e produrre
prime computer quelli che adesso usiamo
tutti i giorni i telefonini che noi
usiamo tutti i giorni il transistor è
basato sui semiconduttori al silicio e i
semiconduttori non li puoi progettare se
non hai la meccanica quantistica Se non
sai la meccanica quantistica e questo ha
cambiato la nostra realtà ha cambiato la
nostra società quindi vedete un cambio
di paradigma l'inizio del Novecento ci
porta a un cambio nella nostra società
più di 100 anni dopo
e adesso stiamo ancora lavorando per
sviluppare il prossimo computer che non
è più un computer classico ma è un
computer quantistico in cui Invece di
usare un B che può essere 01 siamo uno
stato quantistico che 01 nello stesso
momento e questo può produrre molte più
informazioni di quelle che noi siamo in
grado di usare adesso e quindi potremmo
risolvere i problemi che adesso per cui
adesso ancora un 10000 anni in poche ore
vedremo se questo funzionerà è il
prossimo cambio di paradigma nel campo
dei computer
bene
questo sono tre esempi
di cambio di paradigma
di cambio di punto di vista che fanno
fare dei Balzi alla conoscenza e fanno
fare dei Balzi all'umanità
Vediamo le cose da un punto di vista
diverso Capiamo le cose che prima non
avevamo capito
e la tecnologia segue ci sono dei Balzi
nella tecnologia E base nella tecnologia
si riflettono nella nostra vita di tutti
i giorni
cosa possiamo quindi imparare da questi
tre esempi ce ne sono tanti altri dal
1600 in poi ne abbiamo dozzine non
tantissime no almeno una dozzina ci sono
Beh
possiamo imparare che
i cambi di paradigma sono fondamentali
per farli ci vuole ci vogliono delle
persone che guardano la realtà da un
punto di vista diverso e per far questo
ci vuole del coraggio
Perché metti in discussione ciò che
tutti credono e tipicamente quando fai
questo le persone
non ti seguono e devi convincerla E non
è facile quindi bisogna avere il
coraggio di fare queste scelte e di dire
queste cose
Quand'è che avviene un cambio di
paradigma avviene quando io non capisco
un problema che non riesco che non so
risolvere non capisco bene la realtà
è il cambio di paradigma e mi aiuta a
vederlo oppure scopro qualcosa di
inaspettato Ma adesso nel 2000 c'è
qualcosa che non capiamo Beh sì ci sono
molte cose La scienza è molto avanzata
Ma se voi Guardate la luna le stelle le
galassie con un telescopio vedete che
pensate di conoscere l'universo vedete
che si espande Però quando l'ho studiata
in dettaglio scoprire che in realtà
quello che noi vediamo qui nostri
strumenti coi nostri occhi e solo il 5%
dell'universo il 95% non sappiamo cosa
sia
e quindi occorrono dei giovani
coraggiosi che si diano un punto di
vista diverso sull'universo
e quindi questo mi ricorda visto che
questo è un anno particolare mi ricorda
le parole di Dante quando descrive il
viaggio di Ulisse che alle Colonne
d'Ercole convince i compagni ad andare
avanti a cercare l'ignoto e quindi
dice Fatti non foste a viver come bruti
ma per seguir virtute e conoscenza e
quindi i compagni volgono la Poppa al
mattino e con i remi iniziano il Folle
volo folle perché è un volo folle perché
metto in discussione tutto ciò che si
conosce come quando fai un cambio di
paradigma
il ricordo quando mettete in discussione
le cose che sono riconosciute vere si è
prima considerati folle Ma poi se si è
se si ha ragione Si è considerati dei
visionari e quindi io spero che ci siano
tanti giovani coraggiosi e che siano i
visionari della nostra società Grazie
[Applauso]